a lot of literature and videos and blog
posts talk about setting goals and I
hate almost all what I'm going to walk
you through is our four-step goal
setting process and I promise you it's
probably not what you have seen in the
past from basically another company
because I actually didn't take how we
set goals from any business books I
actually took it from a science book
number one is what problem are we
solving a lot of times you realize that
you're not solving a problem at all
which means you probably don't need to
do it this is especially true the lower
in the organization it goes because
people who are lower down in the org
tend to not be as connected to the
overarching picture of the company
simple example most goals have to be
chunked up to one of three things number
one they're going to help us get more
customers number two is that it's going
to help us make customers worth more and
number three it's going to increase the
Enterprise value of the company if you
can't articulate why the goal is going
to do that then you shouldn't do it so
number one pick what problem you're
actually trying to solve simple example
if it decreases the page load times on
all of our sites we will get more leads
we get more leads we get more customers
Etc if it improves the sign-on process
for customers to have access to
something that will mean we have fewer
customers churn which means we will make
customers more valuable if you can't tie
how your department and the function
that you have either gets us more
customers makes them worth more increase
the Enterprise value of the business
means you don't understand your job and
if you're the entrepreneur or the head
of the department you don't know how
you're actually providing value the
business breaking that down is the first
and most important part of goal setting
if this process actually makes you think
that it means you're doing it right
because if you can just knock out your
goals really really fast it probably
means you haven't thought through them
well enough number two we create a
hypothesis and the reason for that is
when you set a goal usually it's like we
want to do this thing right well you're
not actually trying to do the thing
you're hoping that something's going to
happen if you do the thing we like to
Define both of those variables in the
hypothesis for example if I wanted to
have a sales goal it might say something
like if I decrease the time to call
leads from 30 minutes to five minutes we
will get a higher percentage of leads to
book calls that's literally the hardest
part of this whole thing is what is the
hypothesis that you're trying to test
because whenever we actually do
something in the business we're not
guaranteeing the outcome and we're not
guaranteed from the business that it's
going to create the result we want I'm
sure you've tried plenty of things that
have been goals and it didn't result in
the thing that you wanted which is why
you shouldn't state it as a goal
necessarily but as a hypothesis what you
think will happen once you have the what
problem are we solving in your
hypothesis of how you're going to solve
it then you only have two variables that
you have to determine one is what's the
thing I'm going to do which is the
activity that's the input and then what
do I think is going to happen which is
the output number three what are we
going to do we're going to call leads
within five minutes right that is the
input we check that box great output is
we will get a higher percentage of leads
to schedule or show so you'd have your
Baseline of the input which is today
we're at 37 minutes and we want to be at
five that's the input change the output
change is going to be we go from 50
scheduled to 70 schedule that's the
output change that is a goal that is
what we call the before phase the after
phase only has two columns and that's
where you review after the core order is
done or the year is over number four
what do we think is going to happen you
say okay did I do the thing did I do the
input did we actually decrease the call
time to five minutes if we did then
that's a green and here's where this is
important we may have decreased the call
time to under five minutes but we may
not have increased the scheduling at all
that's why it's a hypothesis now did
what I wanted to have happen actually
happen and then that is where you can
put comments here and so what we ended
up doing is we ended up getting it down
to seven minutes and it didn't improve
it at all at this point we don't need to
get it down to five because we didn't
have any directional Improvement it
takes a lot of zero to want a lot of
shiny objects a lot of new things a lot
of trial and error a lot of iterate
iterate iterate until something Clicks
in the beginning but big businesses
often grow by a series of one percent
improvements one percent one percent one
percent because you've seen the excel
math when you're like well if I only got
10 more people to opt in and I got 15
more people to uh schedule and I got 20
more people to show and I closed one
from 25 to 35 you add all this together
and all of a sudden and you tripled the
business and the thing is is that
everyone gets so distracted with like
the I'm going to reinvent the wheel
rather than just making the wheel a
little smoother so it runs faster and so
a lot of times especially in the 5 10 15
20 million dollar Top Line range that's
some of the systems we have to put in
place because that's how the big boys
play they beat you because they actually
can do a hundred tiny increments I think
Jim launch grew 40 last year and we did
nothing new all we did we did everything
we were currently doing a little bit
better if you do that year after year
after year you become very hard to beat
because people see your marketing on the
outside they'll try and copy your pages
they'll try and copy your emails in one
it won't be you so it won't matter
because it's not your story but they
don't know all the internal standard
operating procedures the internal
message that you guys are tracking that
actually create the growth in the
company and a lot of times in the early
business just measuring metrics may be
the important goal for the quarter so
that you can then improve it let's say
your videographer and a marketing
department right each of these goals
should start from the top down so if we
say these are our five goals as a
company the department heads are going
to probably have multi multiple
activities to make the first hypothesis
true or not I like to have everybody as
far down the organization do this
because it actually causes you to think
about why you do what you do a lot of
times employees lose motivation because
they don't know how what they do every
day ties into the bigger picture of how
the company grows and makes more money
with the vdr for example they're like
well what do I do like what problem am I
solving the problem is get more
customers they might not think about it
that way but that's the goal well my
hypothesis is either we might say it's a
volume thing which is if I double the
amount of shorts I make then we will get
more traffic to our website from our
organic content and at the end of the
quarter did you make twice as many
shorts okay green fantastic did that
result in more link clicks on the site
oh it didn't huh interesting I wonder
what would do it okay we need to create
more content that's more story based
great go back to the beginning if we
create more story based content we will
get more link clicks to website that's
why goal setting if done right should
take work because it makes you think why
am I even doing what I'm doing and if
you don't take like a day for a whole
quarter to think why am I even bothering
to do this then why are you bothering to
do it without understanding what you're
trying to improve and the thing is if
you think this way as a teammate or an
entrepreneur I promise you you will be
so much more valuable to your company if
you can even think like a business owner
and this is how a good business owner
should think and if you can approach
whoever runs your company with this
model you may find that they will see
you differently because they're like wow
Timmy who's making these video clips is
actually thinking about what I care
about which is how I'm going to get more
customers whatever the second part of
the statement is if you know what you're
actually trying to accomplish in the
business then it makes a lot easier what
problem are we solving what's our
hypothesis what are we going to do what
do we think is going to happen did we do
it did it happen that's it and so that
has been the simplest goal setting
framework that we've used we use this
across all portfolio companies that's
what we do across everything and it's
been the simplest thing that I've seen I
haven't seen it anywhere else it's
worked for us and maybe it'll work for
you